bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat retour ce matin sur les
conséquences de la suppression de la
taxe professionnelle deux ans et demi
après la mise en place de cette réforme
et de l'instauration d'une contribution
économique territoriale censée compenser
pour les collectivités territoriales
le manque à gagner de la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle
le bilan est plutôt négatif pour les
collectivités locales qui souffrent de
cette réforme c'est le message que les
sénateurs ont souhaité faire passer à
l'occasion d'un débat que je vous
propose de revoir ce matin bonne matinée
à tous l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
du débat sur les conclusions de la
commission commune d'information sur les
conséquences pour les collectivités
territoriales l'état et les entreprises
de la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle de son remplacement par
la contribution économique territoriale
je vous rappelle que nous avions
commencé ce débat le 30 janvier dernier
conformément à la décision de la
conférence des présidents
la parole est à monsieur charles guené
rapporteur de la mission commune
d'information
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a
quelques semaines à travers les trois
fenêtres de tir consentis par nos amis
des loups j'avais pu vous brossez par le
menu les conséquences de la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle mais la plupart
de vous en étaient sortis frustrés de
d'un débat tronqué
aujourd'hui grâce à la pugnacité du
groupe rdse nous pouvons mener à bonne
fin notre exercice
aussi permettez-moi de remercier deux
présidents mézard de m'avoir autorisé
une expression renouvelé bien que
légèrement réduite pour mieux introduire
la discussion attendu au delà des
insuffisances que porte la réforme et
des ajustements qui restent à lui
apporter après plusieurs lois de
finances et que nous examinerons tout
d'abord la seconde partie de mon propos
tentera de vous expliquer comment les
textes impacte profondément le paysage
fiscal est notre conception même des
finances publiques
il est indéniable que la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle à renforcer la
compétitivité des entreprises ainsi que
l'établissent tous les rapports
rappelons que seuls 20% des entreprises
ont été reconnus perdante alors que 20%
connu la stabilité et 60% ont pu
observer les variations de 30 à 80% de
leur imposition essentiellement pour le
secteur industriel au détriment certes
des services et au prix de quelques
désagréments pour l'intérim ans en ce
qui concerne l'état la réforme a eu un
coût de l'ordre de quatre milliards et
demi d'euros en régime de croisière
après une année charnière qui lui en a
coûté le double mais en revanche l'état
a fixé l'hémorragie que lui imposaient
les contreparties aux collectivités
locales au titre de cet impôt et dont il
était le principal pourvoyeur et c'est
là son gain est essentielle
il a en quelque sorte payer pour solde
de tout compte
enfin pour les collectivités locales si
elles ont été indemnisés à l'euro près
ce que plus personne ne conteste la
réforme est venu profondément affecté
leurs relations avec l'état ce que nous
examinerons plus loin
sur le plan pratique l'incidence majeurs
de la réforme et leur base âge de la
ressource sur les ménages notamment pour
le bloc communal et sur une part
d'impôts économique considérablement
diminué et qui évolue désormais au même
rythme que la richesse nationale ce qui
est induit une dynamique nouvelle
corrélé à l'évolution économique et aux
capacités contributrice des habitants
les parlementaires ont à cet égard
durant non en affiner considérablement
les critères pour corriger les énormes
les anomalies et tenir compte du poids
de l'histoire
nous ne reviendrons pas sur ce travail
fastidieux mais le souligneront les
résultats obtenus et les axes à
poursuivre les ajustements pris lors de
ses deux dernières lois de finances au
mieux assurer la prise en compte des
établissements industriels et de leurs
spécificités comme leurs effectifs et
adopter certaines mesures préconisées
par notre rapport sénatorial comme
l'indexation d y faire
à l'heure actuelle subsiste la
problématique liée à la poursuite de la
mise en oeuvre de la période
la péréquation corollaire est
essentielle au nouveau système car le
fondement de la ressource nouvelle des
collectivités et son dynamisme
asymétrique exige une appréciation de la
richesse en stock ainsi que des charges
des collectivités la mise en oeuvre de
ces corrections est l'un des chantiers
essentiels du parlement il importe que
la montée en puissance programmée puis
suivre le calendrier fixé
mais en prenant garde aux contextes le
contraint que nous traversons est encore
lent l'effort au flux annuel pour le
bloc communal nous pouvons nous
féliciter du cap maintenu par le
gouvernement au niveau de la progression
du spic voire même son rattrapage comme
la répartition sur la base du cif le
coefficient d'intégration fiscale au
niveau intercommunal l'introduction du
revenu des habitants qui vient modifier
à hauteur de 20% le prélèvement
constitue une correction utile apportées
par la loi de finances pour 2013 au
profit de certains territoires urbains
le champ d'appréciation des charges de
centralité reste aussi ouvert il
conviendra sans nul doute d'introduire
des correctifs en déplafonnant
progressivement le prélèvement du fric
et du strict mais nous devons aussi
attendre que l'île de france puissent
ajuster son propre système
en tenant compte des besoins spécifiques
et différencier de son territoire qui
n'a pas encore rappelons le opéré sa
mutation intercommunale
il reste beaucoup plus de travail sur le
mécanisme de solidarité des régions et
des départements qui ont apporté moins
d'attention à ces mécanismes
ces collectivités aurait sans doute
intérêt à faire rapidement des
propositions plus concrètes à cet égard
au plan technique il convient d'insister
sur les trois pierres d'achoppement
subsitent subsistantes autour de la
contribution économique territoriale et
en cela j'appellerai l'attention
particulière de monsieur le ministre
tout d'abord le dossier de la cfe
minimale que le gouvernement n'a pas
voulu régler définitivement dans la
dernière loi de finances et pour
laquelle nous avons nous avions proposé
un plafonnement sur la valeur ajoutée à
l'instar de ce qui existe pour les
autres compris louable il est
indispensable de le décider pour 2014 en
temps utile dans un cadre
constitutionnel durable il sera
également impératif d'adapter la
répartition de la cvae aux
caractéristiques des groupes en effet
actuellement les décisions de
l'organisation juridique des groupes
permettent de déterminer largement les
lieux de répartition de la valeur
ajoutée
sachant qu'il réalise plus de la moitié
de sa valeur ajoutée au plan national et
qu'ils sont concentrés sur certaines
zones
le mécanisme n'est pas neutre il était
proposé notre rapport parlementaire que
cet aspect soit corrigée pour ramener
les principes à ceux qui régissent les
entreprises multi établissements
classiques temps valérie pécresse que
son successeur
jérôme cahuzac ont prétexté le besoin de
simulation pour envisager d'en modifier
la proche le phénomène est maintenant
parfaitement identifiés enfin subsistera
la mesure d un dissidence la
revalorisation des valeurs locatives
dont le calendrier est désormais
programmé sept dernières évolutions
fiscales produire à de nouvelles
modifications sur la géographie fiscale
locale
elle viendra tout autant impacter la
fiscalité locale car elles portent en
germe également une nouvelle carte des
richesses et par là même des critères
qui sont utilisés pour la péréquation de
ces mêmes richesses sur les territoires
cette réforme est d'autant plus
nécessaire que la perte du levier fiscal
impose la revalorisation permanente de
la matière fiscale de manière
différenciée convenant à cet égard que
la mise en place d'une nouvelle
fiscalité locale locales qui ne s'appuie
plus pour l'essentiel sur le levier
fiscal doit pouvoir bénéficier d'un
renseignement une expertise et de
rapport permanent qui ne soit pas à la
seule discrétion du gouvernement
il convient que les parlementaires
puissent disposer en permanence de
simulation et des états nécessaire et ne
pas s'en remettre à la seule expertise
de l'arac association d'élus qui leur
fournissent eu certes des rapports de
perspectives intéressant il est urgent
de mettre à disposition des
parlementaires les outils et les
ressources nécessaires à une veille et
une mise à jour permanente la fiscalité
locale
venons en maintenant à l'aspect
prospectifs et aux conséquences les plus
durables de cette réforme la taxe
professionnelle a vu le jour à la fin
des trente glorieuses sur les bases d'un
concept reposant sur une ère de
croissance et une volonté d'autonomie
fiscale et de transferts aux
collectivités locales pour qu'elles
assument elles mêmes les besoins de
reconstruction et de développement en
lieu et place de l'état initiée par des
textes de 1959
rappelons le ce texte arrive à maturité
alors que nous venions tout juste de
changer d'époque avec le choc pétrolier
de 1974 et la fin des budgets en
équilibre en 1975 qui vont placer le
pays en situation de crise situation qui
ne cessera pas et ira crescendo avec la
la mondialisation la taxe
professionnelle en subira très
rapidement les conséquences avec la
suppression de la part salaires en 1987
puis en 1999
au grand dam des finances de l'état puis
avec la prise en compte de la valeur
ajoutée à travers des modifications de
1979 et 2006 qui portait déjà en germe
la réforme de 2009 portées par les seuls
investissements
la taxe professionnelle comme
l'indiquent le rapport fouquet était
condamné alors que les collectivités se
réjouissait de la liberté fiscale
acquise
ailleurs on réfléchissait déjà à de
nouvelles
étape l'état était déjà en période de
contrainte et on va assister à un chassé
croisé de mesures contradictoires avec
avec l'illusion d'une autonomie fiscale
de plus en plus financé par l'état à
travers des des grades des dégrèvements
croissant il faudra attendre cependant
la charnière 2002 2004 avec
l'inscription de l'article 72-2 dans la
constitution pour que l'horizon bascule
cependant à ce moment là le monde et lui
n'a pas perçu la portée de la
disposition le gouvernement et
l'administration venait d'imposer
définitivement la norme de référence
exit le pen a mis fiscale l'autonomie
financière était né en 2009 la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle a priori à
destination des entreprises vient porter
le coup de grâce en diminuant le poids
de l'économie dans la ressource locale
en figeant les taux et en réaffectant
les impôts par niveau et souvent sous
forme de parts d'un fonds national pour
être tout à fait complète cette réforme
exigée un second pilier celui de la
péréquation horizontale
car si elle a réduit le poids de la
richesse économique dans la ressource
elle n'en a pas moins laissé subsister
des inégalités territoriales accumulé en
même temps la réforme permet à l'état de
substituer la péréquation horizontale à
la péréquation verticale dont il était
comptable dernier verrou posé sur les
dispositifs avant que ne vienne
s'ajouter la rationalisation des
compétences qui nous occupera dans les
deux mois à venir
il est important de souligner ce double
mouvement contradictoire où le
cheminement des élus s'est heurté à une
radicalisation de l'administration et
des gouvernements et où les élus ont
accusé un temps de retard par rapport à
l'évolution et au mouvement de
l'histoire 6 4 cela ne signifie pas que
ce mouvement soit inéluctable et ne
puisse traite à l'inversé mais seulement
que les circonstances l'imposent
et pour quelques décennies et qu'il
importe d'en prendre acte
à l'instar de ce que deux à l'instar de
nos collègues européens en sus de mon
propos initial je formulerai une
interrogation supplémentaires en lien
avec la réduction drastique des
notations qui vient de nous être
annoncée quatre milliards et demi sur
deux ans soit 6 % de leur montant
si on peut comprendre une telle décision
dans le contexte que je viens d'évoquer
il importe que ça nécessite et ce
rapidement partagé et qu en outre la
répartition de l'effort au sein des
niveaux de collectivités soit
équitablement répartis
pouvez-vous à cet égard monsieur le
ministre nous dire les intentions du
gouvernement sur le sujet dans le cadre
de la gouvernance qui s'installent pour
terminer sur une note prospective je
voudrais dire que la taxe
professionnelle ne correspond pas
seulement une grande réforme fiscale
technique mais elle doit être lu comme
selon une prophétie une formule
empruntée aux professeurs nouvier le
basculement tangible d'un monde quasi
révolue fondée sur une régulation par
des états nationaux maîtres de leur
choix financier à un autre fondée sur
des espaces supranationaux intégrant des
espaces territoriaux et fonctionnels à
autonomie financière limitée
la crise que nous traversons en accélère
l'évolution avec une violence
inaccoutumée en poussant et le plus
forte intégration des acteurs publics
locaux nationaux et européens et à la
mise en place d'outils nouveaux comme le
conseil des exécutifs ou le cou aux
conseils des territoires demain auquel
nous devons donner force opérationnelle
au plus vite et dans le cadre d'un
véritable dialogue
ce l équilibre de la société du lien
social qui est en jeu avec une nouvelle
forme de gouvernance qui intégrera
démocratie solidarité et liberté
le seul risque que comporte l'exercice
c'est que cette intégration prennent la
voie d'une recentralisation aussi
souhaitons que le parlement ne se
contente pas de considérer cet épisode
comme celui d'une réforme réalisée à apa
à la hâte mais où on souffre ans
d'improvisation n'est comme celle
excusez moi aussi souhaitons que le
parlement ne se contente pas de
considérer cet épisode comme celui d'une
femme qu'elle est apte ou souffrant
l'improvisation ou les uns ou les autres
auraient failli car alors il passerait à
côté de l'histoire fiscale de nos
collectivités
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci dans la suite du débat la parole
et à madame françoise laborde pour le
groupe
rds
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme cela
était rapport appelé le 30 janvier dans
l'espace réservé du rds par le président
mézard notre groupe est à l'origine de
cette demande de débat parce qu'il est
aussi à l'origine de la constitution de
la mission commune d'information mission
qui fut présidée par notre ancien
collègue anne marie escoffier émission
dont les conclusions et le rapport en
deux tomes ont été rendues publiques au
mois de juin 2012
un tel débat avait et a désormais pour
cette seconde partie toute sa place dans
une semaine sénatoriale de contrôle et
c'est pourquoi nous nous réjouissons
qu'il puisse être poursuivi
précisément dans ce cadre là aujourd'hui
ce débat dans notre hémicycle ne pouvait
plus attendre car les conclusions de la
mission commune d'information sur les
conséquences pour les collectivités
territoriales l'état et les entreprises
de la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle et de son remplacement
par la contribution économique
territoriale mérite que le gouvernement
fournisse certains éclaircissements et
informe la haute assemblée de ses
intentions en la matière et plus
largement sur la question de plus en
plus sensible des finances des
collectivités territoriales sur cette
question mon groupe s'enorgueillit de
son orgueil d'être en pointe et de
remplir ainsi la mission que nous
confère à nos sénateurs de la république
l'article 24 de la constitution
désormais les 25 propositions formulées
par la mission d'information sont autant
de pistes pour limiter les dégâts causés
et qui continue de l'être par la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle mais aussi
pour apporter des compléments utiles sur
des points qui n'ont pas été traités
jusqu'à présent malheureusement cette
évaluation des conséquences de la
réforme s'est révélée particulièrement
délicate compte tenu des difficultés
rencontrées par les membres de la
mission pour obtenir certains chiffres
et certaines informations
en effet un des éléments les plus frais
à la lecture de ce rapport est bien le
déficit d'information qu'ont constaté
les auteurs et dont ils ont eux même
souffert je citerai quelques passages
très révélateur le rapport rappelle par
exemple qu aucune estimation n'a été
fourni par le gouvernement
s'agissant des conséquences de la
nouvelle définition des potentiel fiscal
et financier sur le classement des
communes et des opci en fonction de leur
potentiel par habitant à propos des
fonds de péréquation de la cvae
on peut lire je cite votre rapporteur
regrette que malgré les travaux
approfondis menés par la commission des
finances sur ce sujet le gouvernement
n'est procédé à aucune évaluation
détaillée des conséquences de ces
dispositifs de péréquation pour les
départements et les régions
ce constat a conduit les membres de la
mission a recommandé de renforcer les
dispositifs départemental et régional de
péréquation de la cvae et dû simuler
leur est fait en amont de l'examen de la
loi de finances pour 2013
il s'agit de leur 16e proposition de
telles simulations bien été
partiellement fourni avec le projet de
loi de finances pour 2013 dont l'article
revoyez en profondeur le fonctionnement
et les modalités de répartition des
fonds de péréquation de la cvae qui
doivent être mis en place cette année
cependant le rôle des parlementaires est
nécessairement contraint par le fait
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de réaliser
leurs propres simulations et donc
d'élaborer des propositions alternatives
de maintenir éclairer ce qui est tout à
fait regrettable dans une démocratie
parlementaire moderne
il me semble pourtant indispensable que
le parlement dispose de toutes les
simulations nécessaire pour éclairer les
décisions qu'il prend mais nous n'avons
pas tous la même préoccupation
si l'on croit si l'on en croit le vote
des députés qui ont lors de l'examen en
deuxième lecture du plf pour 2013 adopté
un amendement vous
le mental modifiant à nouveau totalement
les modalités de fonctionnement des
fonds de péréquation de la cvae et ce
sans aucune simulation
je pourrais citer de nombreux autres
passages du rapport qui relève l'absence
d'information et de simulation sur tel
ou tel point
ceci est révélateur du peu de cas qui
est fait du rôle et des droits du
parlement et des parlementaires
nous le regrettons et monsieur le
ministre pour puisque vous êtes nouveau
à ce poste
nous espérons que vous faciliterez au
maximum la diffusion des informations
demandées par les parlementaires
notamment à vos services de bercy qui
font parfois de la détention
je reviens maintenant aux conclusions du
rapport de la mission que nous apprend
t-il tout d'abord que l'effet positif
attendu de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle sur les entreprises
n'est pas aussi évident qu'il y paraît
et surtout qu'il n'est pas aussi
mirobolants que ce qu'on nous avait
laissé entrevoir
certes cette réforme a bénéficié à un
nombre non négligeable d'entreprises
notamment dans le secteur industriel
mais trois ans plus tard la situation
n'a pas fondamentalement changé car les
ressorts de notre perte de compétitivité
qui se poursuit depuis plus de dix ans
comme l'a rappelé l'excellent rapport de
louis gallois se trouve ailleurs en
outre cette réforme a été pénalisante
pour un certain nombre de petites
entreprises notamment des artisans et
des commerçants
elle ne s'est pas non plus traduites par
des créations d'emplois
contrairement à ce qui était prévu et
annoncé de nouvelles mesures doivent
donc être prises et mises en place
d'urgence pour restaurer la
compétitivité la croissance et l'emploi
le gouvernement s'y emploie et le groupe
rds la porte tout son soutien pour
poursuivre dans cette voie pour les
collectivités territoriales
le principal constat du rapport est sans
appel la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle a eu pour conséquence de
maintenir les collectivités
territoriales dans un état d'incertitude
quant à leurs ressources fiscales et
budgétaires
certes du chemin a été fait depuis et la
certitude a laissé la place à un très
grand scepticisme car la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle c'est bel et bien
pour reprendre les mots employés par
notre rapporteur charles guené le 30
janvier le coup de grâce porté à
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
les élus rencontrés par les membres de
la mission lors de leur déplacement à
toulouse ont très bien résumé me
semble-t-il
le sentiment général des collectivités
quant à cette réforme
ils ont déploré en effet je cite le
rapport le manque d'informations et de
simulations concernant leurs recettes au
moment de la réforme qui a pu conduire
certains d'entre eux à prendre des
décisions inadaptées
il avait également soulevé à juste titre
le risque d'une augmentation du poids de
l'imposition sur les ménages
un risque qui est aujourd'hui devenu
réalité comme l'a montré le rapport
présenté le 6 novembre 2012 par le
gouvernement
devant le comité des finances locales
pour conclure je dirais que la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle n'a que très
partiellement atteint ses objectifs qui
étaient l'amélioration de la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
d'une part la simplification et la
classification de la fiscalité locale de
l'autre aujourd'hui nous sommes toujours
face aux mêmes défis
je tiens pour terminer à insister sur un
point auquel tous les membres du rds
sont très attachés pour réduire les
inégalités entre les territoires
inégalités qui ne cesse de s'accroître
depuis la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
il est urgent de mettre en place un
système de péréquation verticale et
horizontale verte il hérite ablement
juste et efficace beaucoup de chemin
reste à parcourir pour y arriver mais
nous espérons que le gouvernement ne se
laissera pas ralentir au premier
obstacle
en tout cas il peut compter sur le sénat
y sur le rds pour lui rappeler à la fois
ses engagements et ses obligations
envers les collectivités territoriales
de notre pays
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
jean vincent placé pour le groupe
écologiste
ces présidents seul ministre mes chers
collègues la fiscalité locale comme
nationale relève certes d'un enjeu
pragmatique à savoir quels sont les
moyens dont on dispose pour agir mais
c'est également un enjeu démocratique
puisque le citoyen doit pouvoir juger
les élus en fonction de leur gestion des
deniers publics
or lorsqu'on constate l'état de la
fiscalité locale il ya de quoi
s'inquiéter
dans notre système est peu lisible aux
maquettes et sénateurs je me réjouis que
nous puissions avoir ce débat jean
remercier le groupe rdse et son
président jacques mézard nous les
écologistes aux et mon visage et le
sénat comme la future chambre des
régions si je crois que c'est l'endroit
idéal pour soulever cette question est
particulièrement en amont de notre
réflexion sur la réforme des
collectivités
le rapport d'information de notre
collègue de notre collègue charles guené
fait au nom de la mission commune
d'information sa taxe professionnelle
qui fut fait d'ailleurs sur la
présidence de marianne escoffier
aujourd'hui ministre et que je tiens
également à saluer des rsa très bon un
excellent tableau de la situation et des
conséquences de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
il ya d'ailleurs un point et quand
j'entends les différentes interventions
sur lesquels ne seront probablement tous
d'accord c'est que la taxe
professionnelle n'était pas un impôt
satisfaisant cet axe comprenait en
réalité de nombreuses exonérations
permanentes ou temporaires son assiette
et est à revoir puisque elle reposait
sur une valeur locative obsolète des
immeubles et terrains est pénalisé en
réalité l'investissement des entreprises
il y avait même eu je crois ce propos de
dire cette taxe imbécile
aussi nous avons un peu de mémoire enfin
et pousser très cher aux finances
publiques de l'état puisque la puissance
publique se substituer bien souvent aux
entreprises la cour grâce à des
compensations et dégrèvement pour
devenir au final le coron premier
contribuable la taxe professionnelle ces
dérives ont profondément remis en cause
le principe constitutionnel même selon
lesquelles ressources propres des
collectivités territoriales représentent
pour chaque catégorie de collectivité
une part déterminante de l'ensemble de
leurs ressources
nous pourrons en effet déploré que
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
radicalement diminué depuis l'acte 2 de
la décentralisation la fin de la tp
était inévitable
a mis beaucoup de temps à s'opérer
certainement beaucoup trop de temps dans
cet axe encore plus lisible et absurdes
comme j'ai pu le dire alors sa
suppression n'a pas été forcément dans
le sens d'un meilleur respect des
principes de la décentralisation
c'est un débat que nous devons mener ses
intérêts de la discussion
la nouvelle contribution économique des
territoires c'est été mise en place
mon texte et d'un précipitation je veux
dire très rapidement est assez opaque et
renforce encore davantage à perte
d'autonomie fiscale des territoires
tandis que les collectivités prennent en
charge le quotidien des français
l'aménagement du territoire les
transports les dépend de la solidarité
et d'accompagnement économie des
territoires
la formation professionnelle est de plus
en plus et politique culturel sanitaire
et j'en passe elle continue de vivre
avec des budgets étriqués dont ils ne
maîtrisent quasiment pas les taux ni
l'assiette les collectivités constitue
on le sait un véritable rempart en
faveur la protection des services
publics les assurent plus de 70 %
presque 80 de l'ensemble des
investissements publics et elle assume
toujours plus de compétences en raison
du désengagement de l'état
or la part des recettes fiscales
correspondant à des impôts dans les
collectivités territoriales vote les
taux deviennent de plus en plus marginal
je suis élu régional je le vois tous les
jours et on voit qu'on ne contrôle plus
beaucoup de ressources fiscales je vois
le président patriat qui connaît ça bien
mieux que moi et qui opine
je le remercie par ailleurs il existe
une véritable incohérences dans cette
réforme puisque elle rompt le lien entre
l'implantation d'entreprises et
collectivités territoriales notamment
les régions pourtant chef de file en
matière économique on vient de le dire
cette réforme a d'ailleurs eu des
conséquences plutôt négative et
1 et face sur la situation économique de
nombreuses entreprises notamment les
plus petites qui doivent aussi de la
cotisation foncière minimale entreprise
a quitté des sommes très difficile à
assumer
l'acef la contribution française
entreprises et ont été particulièrement
mal pensé les collectivités locales
qu'ils ont voté non pas eu les moyens de
calculer les conséquences financières de
cette nouvelle ces feux forfaitaire pour
les contribuables
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi le sénat
par la voix de françois marque que je
salue le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances a proposé de
revenir sur les modalités de fixation
des bases de calcul la cotisation
minimale l'acf
je me réjouis de l'actuel gouvernement
votre prédécesseur jérôme cahuzac que je
salue pour sa qualité son son talent et
je suis sûr monsieur le ministre à la
caisse d'oeuvre que vous irez dans ses
pas je me réjouis que le gouvernement
est acté la disposition qui rendrait à
ces collectivités la possibilité de
revenir sur des délibérations déjà prise
à l'instar de la taxe professionnelle
nous constatons chaque année des
conséquences et les effets pervers de la
cgt que nous devons de corriger je crois
que nous devons envisager une réforme
ambitieuse qui doit être consensuelle
qui préserve les intérêts des uns et des
autres qui réserve qui respect tout à la
fois l'efficacité économique
l'égalité des territoires le principe de
libre administration et d'autonomie
fiscale des collectivités territoriales
de plus sa fiscalité locale doit être
enfin pensé comme un instrument
politique et marquer une rupture avec la
conception administrative des
collectivités territoriales peut être
héritée du passé
la situation actuelle nous interroge sur
le fonctionnement démocratique de cette
république nous souhaitons nous les
écologistes la plus décentralisée
possible comment encourager par son vote
au contraire sanctionner la politique
locaux lorsque ces derniers ne sont pas
en fait responsable de l'évolution de la
fiscalité locale et à la quand même un
souci démocratique évident pour une
meilleure lisibilité et en ma qualité
d'écologistes croit également qu'il est
essentiel de respecter le principe du
décideur payeurs c'est à dire que
l'instance qui décide de la dépense doit
être la même que celle qui engage cette
dépense sur les ressources dont elle est
responsable cela paraît un peu évident
un peu lapalissade mais aussi nahd c'est
peut-être pas trop mal de rappeler cela
pour plus globalement il pour conclure
je souvenir est également l'importance
d'envisager une taxe qui ne
favorise pas l'étalement urbain pour un
meilleur respect de l'environnement et
de la biodiversité grâce à la fiscalité
locale
nous voulons nous pouvons aussi
promouvoir des comportements écologiques
nous pourrions par exemple réfléchir à
l'établissement d'une fiscalité locale
spécifique afin d'empêcher que les
terrains agricoles non constructible
puisse être l'objet de spéculation ou
encore une modulation la dotation
générale de fonctionnement en fonction
des actions relevant de l'ensemble des
critères du développement durable
ce sont des pistes que nous lançons dans
ce débat la fiscalité le cas ça ne peut
pas être évidemment que de la
comptabilité
c'est avant tout un millier un levier au
service de nos politiques publiques et
de la démocratie je crois que ici ces
travaux je les dis du président gainey
et de la demande du président du groupe
rdse d'avoir cette réflexion sur la taxe
professionnelle j'espère d'ailleurs que
nous pourrons l'avoir plus globalement
sur l'ensemble des finances locales
telle fiscalité locale je crois que ce
serait utile à notre pays comme il est 6
heures 56 minutes 59 seulement d'arrêter
là je remercie beaucoup d'autres
attentions
merci à vous merci la parole est à
madame marie hélène des esgaulx pour le
groupe ump
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je commencerai mon
propos par un constat la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle et la mise en place
de la contribution économique
territoriale par nicolas sarkozy n'ont
pas été remises en cause par françois
hollande le 7 mars 2012
l'actuel président de la république
alors candidat reconnaissez que je le
cite cette réforme de la taxe
professionnelle a pu avoir des effets
positifs sur un certain nombre
d'entreprises et tant mieux
nous n'allons pas rétablir la taxe
professionnelle nous prendrons cette
réforme pour ce qu'elle est mais nous la
corrige euros pour ses excès le groupe
ump ne dit pas mieux
je pense que nous pouvons presque tous
nous retrouver de manière consensuelle
sur un tel sujet la création de la
contribution économique territoriale
n'est pas un aboutissement
elle est une étape importante de la
réforme de notre impôt économique local
mais cette réforme est encore appelée à
évoluer
elle est perfectible la partie salaire
de la taxe professionnelle avait été
progressivement supprimés entre 2000 et
2002 par dominique strauss kahn et
n'existe plus depuis le 1er janvier 2003
avec la création de la cité c'est la
partie investissement productif qui a
été supprimé de l'assiette de la taxe
professionnelle mais il s'est agi d'une
réforme nécessaire elle fut complexe à
rédiger un peu nous rappelons nous le
travail crucial qui fut menée ici au
sénat et qui permit de profondément
remanié la réforme initialement proposée
par le gouvernement
notre travail fut je dirais trans
partisan nous introduisent hymne
notamment une clause de revoyure qui
signifie bien que la réforme n'était pas
achevée et sans doute perfectible au
regard des conséquences de son
application concrète qui pouvaient
diverger des simulations c'est ainsi que
notre commission des finances s'est
emparé il ya quelques semaines du
problème de la cotisation foncière des
entreprises
la cfe dont le relèvement en 2012 de la
base minimum
elle par certaines collectivités qui ne
disposait pas alors de simulation a
entraîné une taxation excessive de
certains articles de certains artisans
et commerçants sur l'initiative de notre
commission nous avons adopté à
l'unanimité un amendement autorisant les
communes à délibérer à nouveau sur cette
cotisation minimum de ces feux pour 2012
au final si à l'assemblée nationale dans
le collectif budgétaire de fin d'année
qu'un dispositif a été adoptée
définitivement l'hiver amendements de la
majorité de l'opposition ainsi autoriser
les opci à revenir sur leurs
délibérations de 2012 en réalisant une
nouvelle délibération c'est ce qu'ont 21
janvier 2013
en donnant la possibilité aux
collectivités territoriales de diminuer
ou annuler une part de l'acf voter cette
difficulté fut donc résolue de manière
consensuelle la réforme si elle doit
être encore améliorée ne sera pas remise
en cause car ses effets positifs ont été
indéniable pour notre industrie
à l'heure où le gouvernement parle de
réindustrialisation de redressement
productif de compétitivité la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle a eu des effets
bénéfiques dans ce domaine la
suppression des investissements
productifs de l'assiette de l'impôt
économique local à favoriser la
compétitivité des entreprises
industrielles selon bercy
elle a généré 7,5 milliards d'euros
d'allègements pour les entreprises en
2010 puis 4 milliards d'euros par an au
total 2 millions d'entreprises sont
sorties gagnantes de la réforme contre
moins de 800 milles qui ont constaté une
augmentation de leurs cotisations de
plus de 10% et plus de 500 euros selon
bercy
le premier bénéficiaire de la réforme en
2010 et le secteur de l'industrie qui a
profité une baisse d'impôts de près de 2
milliards d'euros soit 26 % de
l'allègement global mais il est faux de
dire mes chers collègues cette réforme a
favorisé les grandes entreprises les pme
s'en sortent en effet mieux alors que
les grandes entreprises dont le chiffre
d'affaires excède 250 millions d'euros
qui produisent au total 33% à valeur
ajoutée nationale ne représente que 10
% de gain global a contrario les
entreprises de moins de 1 million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires mais
déficit de 30 6 % des allégements selon
bercy
c'est donc parmi les plus grandes
entreprises que les perdants sont
proportionnellement les plus importants
par ailleurs l'effet d'aubaine a été
évité pour certaines grandes entreprises
non délocalisables avec l'instauration
de l'ifr lié feu vert une taxe
forfaitaire sur les entreprises de
réseaux qui neutralisent pour elle les
bénéfices de la réforme
ainsi le caractère jugé parfois quelque
peu anti économique de la taxe
professionnelle car fondées sur la
valeur des investissements et la masse
salariale a été je dirais en grande
partie corrigée il s'agit en fait d'un
rééquilibrage
car lors de la création de la taxe
professionnelle en 1975 à la place de la
patente 15% les assujettis virent leur
cotisation en impôt économique local
augmenter de plus de 70 % dont notamment
les entreprises industrielles les
bénéficiaires de la réforme d'alors
furent les petites entreprises
commerciales et artisanales donc d'un
dispositif fiscal en quelques lignes les
correctifs apportés au fur et à mesure
des années en firent un dispositif de
plusieurs pages extrêmement complexe
pour autant cet impôt économique local
il est indispensable
la cnt d'aujourd'hui comme l'ancienne
taxe professionnelle est une ressource
essentielle des collectivités
territoriales et revêt une grande
importance pour le développement de la
coopération intercommunale
elle a également une place centrale dans
les politiques de péréquation les
inégalités de richesse fiscale entre les
collectivités la suppression d'une
partie de l'assiette de la taxe
professionnelle lors de la création de
la société n'a pas pour autant un pacs
et les ressources des collectivités
puisque le compensation relais leur a
été versée par l'état en 2010 avant la
mise en place à partir de 2011 de
mécanismes de garantie et l'attribution
d'un nouveau panier de ressources
composé de nouvelles recettes fiscales
rétrocédé par l'état la taxe sur les
surfaces commerciales
le solde de la taxe sur les conventions
d'assurance la fraction de des mnt au
qui était encore perçu par l'état et une
partie des frais de gestion de la
fiscalité directe locale revenant
auparavant à l'état alors la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle
je dirais qu'elle a ainsi profondément
modifié le panier des ressources des
collectivités mais aussi leur
distribution sur le territoire les
départements et les régions furent les
catégories de collectivités les plus
impactés par la réforme du fait de la
quasi disparition du levier de taux pour
l'un et la suppression totale pour
l'autre mais plusieurs mécanismes ont
été établis qui ont permis d'améliorer
fortement la péréquation informe père
équateur de cvae pour les deux niveaux
de collectivités et un fonds de
perruques lassus de péréquation ddm t au
pour les départements pour ce qui
concerne les dm théo alors qu'en 2008
les montants pouvait varier de 300 euros
par habitant pour les alpes-maritimes à
50 par habitant pour la haute marne
je peux savoir au hasard monsieur le
rapporteur un autre excellent rapporteur
charles guené connais bien bien sûr
cette question donc c'est un rapport
deux heures à 6 quand même et donc les
écarts ont été réduits grâce à la
création du fonds de péréquation ddm t
au dans le mécanisme de redistribution a
été amélioré au fur et à mesure des lois
de finances et notamment sous
l'impulsion du groupe ump au sénat
la péréquation est en effet un enjeu
essentiel sur lequel nous sommes
fortement engagés depuis la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle
le sénat a notamment obtenu de nouvelles
avancées en faveur des territoires
ruraux et territoires défavorisés je
pense par exemple au dispositif voté
lors de l'examen de la loi de finances
pour 2011 la création du fonds de
péréquation des recettes intercommunales
et communales a également été une
avancée décisive en matière de
péréquation
en résumé la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle a été complexe mais
était nécessaire elle a été corrigée
très substantiellement par le sénat et
la clause de revoyure permet d'en
corriger les imperfections
elle est encore très serré
tellement perfectible mais ses effets
positifs sur les entreprises
industrielles notamment et les pme sont
importants dans un contexte de
déliquescence de notre industrie et de
perte de compétitivité les ressources
des collectivités territoriales n'ont
pas été impactés grâce à des mécanismes
de garantie et de compensation le panier
de ressources fiscales a été très
positivement diversifiée et la
péréquation a été améliorée au final
avec le recul le groupe ump qui avait
soutenu et participé à l'amélioration de
cette réforme
j'ai donc que si elle est encore
perfectible elle a été positive et elle
était nécessaire pour notre pays je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à présent bien me
frédérique espagnac pour le groupe
socialiste
messieurs président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues il y a plus de trois
ans c'était cuit cycle amorcé la
discussion relative à la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle
l'ampleur de cette réforme et les
conséquences profondes qu'elle a eu pour
nos territoires comme la complexité des
dispositifs nécessite au moment où nous
fêtons débattre des perspectives que
nous fassions bilan réfléchie de la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
il y a trois ans un de nos collègues y
avait eu cette phrase au moment de
d'aborder l'article 2 du projet de loi
de finances en 2010 qui portait sur la
suppression de la tp cette réforme menée
par surprise à l'elysée n'a connu que
les couleurs de bercy pour grandir or ce
sont bien les territoires qui demain
mourront de votre fausse réforme
maintenant que ceux des rapports comme
celui remis en novembre 2012 par le
gouvernement au parlement établissent
des bilans objectif réfléchie basée sur
trois années d'exercice post réforme
je ne peux résister à l'envié de vous
rappeler mes chers collègues la réponse
du rapporteur général de l'époque à la
commission des finances monsieur
philippe marini tout ce qui est excessif
est insignifiant cité-etat laurent n'est
pas toujours opportun et cet échange
apparaît aujourd'hui bien douloureux
pour la majorité de l'époque messieurs
mais la douleur est également partagé
par l'ensemble des acteurs locaux des
départements comme des régions des
communes comme des intercommunalités
car oui dans cette rue
tout a été excessif impréparation tout
d'abord pour une réforme annoncée par
surprise un soir de février par nicolas
sarkozy aucune concertation aucune
simulation non plus accompagné d'une
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
précipitations ensuite pour un texte
arrivait dans la foulée de l'assemblée
nationale puis au sénat et discuter dans
des conditions indignes du parlement
dont beaucoup d'entre vous se
souviennent la taxe professionnelle
c'est une masse de plus de 300 milliards
d'euros en 2009 soit près de 18 % des
recettes de fonctionnement de l'ensemble
des collectivités locales cela
reviendrait pour l'état à remplacer
l'impôt sur le revenu qui pèse pour près
de 17 % de ses recettes fiscales
il y a eu nous pouvons le dire
maintenant que nous sommes en
responsabilité et que nous avons la
charge de redresser ce qui a été cassé
il a eu de l'irresponsabilité dans la
façon de mener la réforme fiscale du
territoire et non dans le cas qui nous
intéresse ce qui est excessif est loin
d'être insignifiant dans le cas précis
des départements bien entendu l'effet
ciseau qu'il connaît sur les finances
depuis plusieurs années s'explique en
partie par le rythme de croissance des
dépenses sociales qu'ils doivent assumer
mais la réforme a largement à g et la
possibilité pour eux de se donner des
marges de manoeuvre levier fiscal
étouffés ressources peu dynamiques
dispositifs de péréquation tardant à
voir le jour
à ce titre la réforme territoriale de
2010 a constitué un leurre en abordant
la question de la clause générale de
compétences des collectivités locales
quel département peut aujourd'hui
sérieusement envisagé de mener des
actions sur les projets dépassant son
coeur de métier les prestations de
solidarité
françois patriat s'exprimera sur les
régions mais là encore une donnée les
impositions le sur lesquelles elles
peuvent moduler les to ne porte plus que
sur peu de 10% de leurs ressources
contre 30% avant la réforme
soyons sérieux quelle autonomie fiscale
quel avenir pour une collectivité locale
dont le pouvoir de déterminer et de
moduler l'impôt porte quasi
excessivement sur les cartes grises
enfin le choc communal
j'ai eu l'occasion de suivre lancer dans
mon département des pyrénées atlantiques
les discussions relatives au schéma
départemental de coopération
intercommunale la fameuse cdc chacun
d'entre nous a pu faire dans son
expérience de ces négociations
force est de constater que les
discussions entre l'intercommunalité
commune achète bien souvent sur des
facteurs financiers et fiscaux
l'épouvantail de la réforme fiscale de
1009 est dans tous les esprits lorsqu'il
s'agit d'imaginer les mariages censé
aboutir à cette fameuse rationalisation
de la carte intercommunale
la réforme a rendu illisibles les enjeux
et leurs relations financières entre
l'intercommunalité et les communes là où
elle est censée permettre une
simplification de l'ensemble
quelques exemples un basculement
généralisé vers la fiscalité touchant
les ménages pour les collectivités de
proximité que sont les communes
l'intercommunalité le lien qui existait
avant la réforme entre l'entreprise et
le territoire a en partie disparu
aujourd'hui on le voit bien pour ces
territoires ce sont les zones
résidentielles qui paie et non plus les
zones d'activités l'accueil des
entreprises pour une réforme intervenue
en pleine crise économique et qui avait
pour intention de remettre au centre du
jeu les acteurs économiques
le constat est cruel le jeu de dupes
constitué par la réforme territoriale
lancée dans la foulée de la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle en
bouleversant les équilibres financiers
entre collectivités entre territoires la
droite ne voulait que transformer les
discussions de périmètre intercommunal
pendant intercommunaux en bataille
rangée bataille menée par un épais
brouillard qui n'a pas fini aujourd'hui
de s'est dissipée chaque année les
clauses de revoyure que la droite nous
avait tant vantée ont en réalité est l
occasion de dizaines d' ajustement
technique parfois essentiels qui n'avait
pu être traités au moment de la réforme
le bilan est une étape obligée nous ne
sont pas dans la posture nous avons
suffisamment eu l'occasion de nous faire
part de vos critiques à l'encontre de
cette réforme bâclée mais les faits nous
donnent malheureusement largement raison
aujourd'hui comme sur d'autres sujets
nous avons l'ambition de redresser ce
qu'ils avaient été maltraités ces
dernières années et contre lesquels nous
étions dressé depuis l'élection de
françois hollande de nombreuses mesures
ont été prises discutée et votée au
parlement dont certaines à l'initiative
du groupe socialiste du sénat pour les
centaines de milliers de petites
entreprises qui ont été cet automne les
victimes de collatéral d'une énième
épisode de la fin d'un taxe
professionnelle et ont subi des hausses
d'impôts injustifiées
nous avons pris l'initiative de faire
voter une disposition permettant aux
collectivités de réparer cette injustice
pour les territoires c'est la révision
des valeurs locatives que nous avons
portée de nos voeux et que nous avons
fait avancer en décembre dans cet
hémicycle
ce serpent demain est une réforme
majeure puisqu'elle touchera la
substance même de l'ensemble des
ressources fiscales perçues par les
collectivités
mais là où la réforme fiscale 2009 avait
mené en quelques semaines
nous souhaitons un calendrier réa
raisonnable et efficace qui laisse la
place à l'expérimentation et à la
concertation pour les collectivités
locales enfin car les débats que nous
avons eus cet automne sur la péréquation
des ressources entre territoires
continuera tout au long de 2013 pour
permettre là encore de combattre les
injustices qui ont été figés dans la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
après sinon de majorité n'a eu de cesse
que nous rappeler des mots de françois
mitterrand évoquant la taxe
professionnelle impôt un peu des
imbéciles mais bien entendu que cette
taxe de demander une vaste réforme de la
fiscalité locale qu'ils uniraient pour
une imposition qui avait connu près de
70 modification par voie législative
mais un impôt imbécile
n'appelez pas une réforme ratée justice
donc pour les territoires cette valeur
cardinale est au coeur de notre
engagement socialiste a fortiori dans la
chambre des collectivités locales à
l'injustice fiscale qu'il transparaît
désormais accrue par la réforme
succéderait la restriction des libertés
locales
c'est contre le fatalisme d'une réforme
bâclée que nous travaillons et que nous
porterons le débat et nos propositions
c'est prochainement dans cette assemblée
merci merci la parole à jean marie
bockel pour le groupe
udi uc
le président mais c'est le ministre mes
chers collègues
force est de constater que la réforme de
la taxe professionnelle constituer une
bonne initiative au premier regard
s'inscrivant à priori dans une démarche
de simplification de la fiscalité
économique local avec pour objectif de
développer la compétitivité des
entreprises en allégeant leurs charges
fiscales à travers la suppression de la
taxation sur les investissements
productifs c'est une démarche qui vient
de loin je me souviens qu'il ya déjà une
dizaine d'années ce que ce présidé
l'association des grandes villes de
france nous avions des discussions avec
les entreprises avec le gouvernement de
l'époque
il ya eu également le rapport lambert
des tables rondes enfin c'est une
démarche qui n'est pas tombée du ciel il
ya quelques années et on en comprend
l'esprit toutes collectivités confondues
la tp représentait 45% des recettes
fiscales 18 % des recettes de
fonctionnement et le produit payé par
les entreprises étaient de l'ordre de 30
milliards d'euros c'est dire si cette
réforme à bouleverser le schéma de
fiscalité locale sans pour autant donner
aux acteurs locaux les outils
nécessaires à leur dynamisme
en 2010 les collectivités ont perçu une
compensation relais qui s'est substitué
à l'atp très bien mais en 2011 leurs
ressources fiscales ont connu des
changements importants en raison de la
mise en place du nouveau panier fiscal
perçu en lieu et place de l'atp c'est là
que les difficultés vont commencer
en effet il y avait au début le principe
de la compensation intégrale et de l'
équilibre
mais qu'en est il aujourd'hui que
peut-on attendre de l'évolution à venir
la contribution économique territoriale
at elle vocation à devenir une ressource
dynamique pour soutenir l'investissement
public ou s'agit-il simplement de
garantir un équilibre fixé à la seule
année 2010
arrêt porte la réforme à l'époque nous
apparaît c'est financièrement neutres
mais sur le moyen et long terme des
transferts de ressources sont bien avoir
un effet différent selon le poids des
différentes composantes du nouveau
panier fiscal de chaque collectivité
notamment dans leur potentiel de
croissance respectifs au risque de créer
des situations à géométrie variable en
fonction des territoires et des
collectivités jusqu'à rompre la
solidarité de ses territoires et creuser
une facture territoriale difficilement
supportable tant pour nos concitoyens
que pour les collectivités
en somme le nouveau panier fiscal ne
connaît pas une croissance aussi
soutenue que celle enregistrée par les
bases de tp
les leviers fiscaux dont disposent les
collectivités sont aujourd'hui moins
important qu'auparavant avec une
autonomie fiscale réduite et une perte
de dynamisme des bases
le tout dans une situation économique
général particulièrement tendue que nous
avons tous souligné et je voudrais
reprendre certains aspects tout d'abord
là c était plafonné à 3 % la valeur
ajoutée des contribuables au lieu de
trois et demi pour l'atp ce qui réduit
le recours au levier fiscal
la collectivité vote les taux de ces
feux mais celui de la cvae et national
est figé à 1,5 pour cent et il est lié à
la révolution nationale internationale
est naturellement
du coup il est fortement ralentie
monsieur le ministre dans le contexte
actuel de crise économique et de
mutation profonde de notre territoire
ces mécanismes ne sont ils pas de nature
à affecter le dynamisme des
collectivités locales en amputant leur
capacité d'investissement
à un moment on attend beaucoup ses
investissements notamment dans le monde
de l'entreprise tout en accroissant leur
dépendance à l'égard de l'état je veux
j'ai à l'esprit on a tous évidemment
d'autres vies qu locale le devenir de
mon agglomération mulhousienne
en 2011 nous avons actionné le
modérément le levier des taux
d'imposition l'acfe la taxe d'habitation
nous avons agi sur la fiscalité
additionnelle nous avons mis en place
notre politique d'abattement de taxe
d'habitation pour arriver au niveau de
ressources nécessaires pour couvrir les
dépenses
nous avons dû agir sur deux postes à ses
feux et des impôts ménages puisque les
autres recettes étaient figées et
évidemment nous avons subi une perte de
dynamisme que nous avons chiffré ce
regard des évolutions des dernières
années avant la réforme de l'ordre de
1.5 millions d'euros par an c'est
évidemment important
et puis à partir de 2012 évidemment on a
vu aussi des limites de ce levier fiscal
dans le contexte de crise que vivent à
la fois les entreprises et les ménages
et nous sommes engagés car il ya
toujours moyen de faire dans une
politique d'économies avec évidemment
une fiscalité extrêmement modéré
d'économies qui naturellement pèsera sur
nos investissements pèsera sur les
services à la population nous essayons
de le faire de manière raisonnable
équilibré mais ça n'est évidemment pas
neutre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
évidemment comme tous mes collègues je
me pose
certain nombre de questions sur le bilan
actuel de cette réforme alors
naturellement tout n'est pas noir tout
n'est pas blanc
je pense qu'il ne faut pas avoir j'ai
écouté avec intérêt le propos de notre
collègue espagnac ou peut-être quelque
peu manichéen
je pense que d'ici quelques mois ou
quelques années lorsque vous aurez
améliorer la méthode nous comptons sur
vous lorsque vous aurez pris en compte
la situation économique les attentes des
collectivités la justice fiscale
peut-être porterez-vous un jugement plus
nuancé sur la difficulté de l'exercice
auquel nous sommes confrontés c'était
vrai avant-hier c'était vrai hier c'est
vrai aujourd'hui
moi très objectivement je reconnais que
la méthode n'a pas toujours été parfaite
loin s'en faut mais en même temps dans
ce domaine l'art est difficile
aujourd'hui nous hésitons à agir sur le
levier fiscal
c'est certain et donc nous irons sur le
levier de la dépense sur le levier les
investissements ce sera forcément
préjudiciable
et je pense que c'est une question
évidemment qu'on doit se poser est dans
un bon esprit avec le gouvernement car
le sait bien
l'essentiel aujourd'hui des
investissements des investissements
créateurs d'emplois des investissements
dans le btp qui est en crise viennent
des collectivités locales et donc plus
attendons beaucoup évidemment du
dialogue que nous aurons d'autres chats
temps entre le parlement et le
gouvernement pour arriver à parfaire
cette méthode en d'éliminer les effets
pervers et retrouver l'esprit original
de original originel pardon est très
positif de cette réforme
merci je passe la parole à françois
patriat pour le groupe socialiste
ce président du ministre sera porteur
une chers collègues le ministre cette
discussion sur la réforme de la tp a
commencé avec jérôme cahuzac il ya
quelques semaines je voudrais ici m'a
aussi le rendre hommage pour le travail
qu'il accomplit la compétence l'énergie
qu'il y a misé salué les efforts qu'il a
le nez dans le rétablissement des
comptes publics
et vous souhaiter à vous bien entendu
parce que je connais à la fois votre
énergie votre clairvoyance votre
intelligence
bonne chance dans la suite de cette
fonction difficile à un moment difficile
pour notre pays
nous sommes là aujourd'hui pour faire le
bilan d'une réforme dont certains
vendent tous les mérites dans d'autres
qu'elle est totalement négatif n'a pas
été propos de madame espagnac auxquelles
je crois que mesurer ses propos tout à
l'heure dans ce qui a été une réforme
que moi je considère comme à la fois
brutale coûteuse et inefficace
son nier la nécessité de cette réforme
d'un impôt qualifié vous l'avez dit par
beaucoup d'éléments dont l' impôt
imbécile
elle avait deux vertus cette réforme sur
ministre première vertu elle voulait
mettre fin à la fois à des iniquités et
à fois les transferts vers l'état de
faire en sorte qu' il y ait un impôt sur
les entreprises qui soit juste efficace
et qui permettent aux collectivités
d'avoir des ressources nécessaires mais
il avait aussi une arrière-pensée
c'est la personne ne l'a évoqué
aujourd'hui c'était à travers cette
arrière-pensée de régler le compte avec
des collectivités considéré comme non
amis et pour lesquelles on voulait bien
chaque jour qu'elles assument des
charges suffisantes nécessaire et
nouvelles notes on ne voulait pas
qu'elle bénéficie des ressources et
quand je dis
cette réforme a été brutale l'a été
parce que c'est eddy par beaucoup
d'entre nous elle a été fait soit
concertation réelle sans évaluation
réelle elle a été faite à la hussarde un
peu dans l'esprit de la loi tepa qui
devait vous souvenez vous créer un choc
de confiance un choc de croissance il
faire croire que par là même on allait
résoudre le problème de la compétitivité
elle a été coûteuse
arrêtez coûteuse parce qu'elle a coûté
et c'est gilles carez qui le dit au lieu
des 3 milliards 6 eskimos n'est pas plus
du double en tout cas la première année
vous l'avez dit tout alors monsieur le
rapporteur - ensuite c'est vrai plus tôt
elle a fait partie de cette dépense qui
avec la loi tepa ont accru le déficit de
la france 2 nous sommes aujourd'hui
comptable et que nous devons réparer
aujourd'hui elle a été injuste aussi
parce que à quoi bon tout à l'heure vous
avez donné les chiffres de répartition
madame des esgaulx l'a dit disons les
grands n'ont pas pas vraiment bénéficié
ici à quoi servait-il de diminuer la
taxe professionnelle d'areva d'edf de
carrefour d'autres entreprises voudront
d'entreprise pour mettre à bas les
collectivités par ailleurs et puis là et
c'est injuste parce que moi je connais
des hôtes et y des entreprises
d'insertion qui emploie des centaines
voire des milliers de jeunes chinois qui
ont vu leur taxe x 7 x 7 et qui disent
aujourd'hui ne pourront plus assumer nos
fonctions sur le territoire là il s'agit
de l'aide directe à l'emploi des jeunes
et jeunes sortis du système d'imagés
donc qu'elle était coûteuse alors pour
les collectivités je me souviens du
cynisme d'un ancien membre du
gouvernement qui rencontrons avec moi
des élus locaux en puisaye dans la
gourgane disait effectivement cette
réforme elle est bonne pour les communes
pas mal et bien pour l'intercommunalité
pour le département sera meilleure pour
les régions c'est vrai nous n'aurons
rien pierre vachon et n'auront rien
alors les régions parlons-en un peu un
instant nous avions à l'époque 30% de ce
qu'on appelle autonomie fiscale
il nous en est resté à l'issue de la
réforme 10% 9 % et quels impôts alala
les impôts c'est les cartes grises et la
taille pépé dont le disait qu'il était
inapte au porteur d'avenir
vous comprenez bien qu'aujourd'hui pour
les collectivités locales à la fois les
cartes grises elles sont en baisse
la tei pp nous faisons tous dans les
régions pour en diminuer la consommation
dont nous avons des ressources autonomes
qui sont en baisse mais plus aucun
pouvoir
parce que dans le même temps vous auriez
pu laisser les taux aux collectivités
pour leur donner une part de
responsabilité vous n'avez pas fait vous
avez laissé le taux à l'état donc nous
avons aujourd'hui je le dis à plusieurs
reprises et tribune un budget affecté
les régions on t'a budget affecté
on leur dit voilà
budget il va encore diminuer dans les
années qui viennent mais avec ça il
faudra faire plus parce qu'on demandait
aux collectivités de dire mais restez
dans vos compétences mais pourquoi on en
même temps ne reviendriez vous pas il
faut venir sur les tgv sur les
autoroutes ce l'innovation sur les plan
campus sur le développement industriel
et sur l'aménagement du territoire ou
sur le très haut débit
les collectivités ont par ce fait tout à
l'heure a été évoqué le ciseau mais en
grande difficulté alors je pense que
depuis les temps a changé c'est vrai
cette réforme n'a pas eu que des effets
négatifs je le dis ici
mais tous sont d'accord pour dire
qu'elle doit être améliorée on doit
aller au delà monsieur liste on doit
repenser aujourd'hui à la fois les
missions des collectivités locales mais
aussi leurs ressources
il faut que nous ayons des ressources
qui correspondent à nos compétences se
veut dire quoi pour les régions des
régions qui ont en charge les trains les
ter dont on souligne aujourd'hui que
l'essai de l'avoir transféré aux régions
est un effet bénéfique avec des hausses
de fréquentation 30% de l'amélioration
des services locaux mais donner aux
régions la responsabilité des ter dans
le même temps asseoir leurs sourcils ati
pp avouez qu'il ya quand même une
incongruité que nous devons réparer donc
il faut demain redéfinir les compétences
des collectivités ce sera l'objet de la
loi futur il faudra aussi redéfinir
leurs ressources
je crois qu'il faut les accès sur ce qui
sera la responsabilité de chacune des
collectivités et ça pour ce faire nous
avons en région des ressources
aujourd'hui les opérateurs sur les
moyens de transport sur lesquels sur
lesquels nous agissons vraiment qu'ils
puissent permettre demain d'avoir aux
collectivités que les collectivités
puissent assumer leurs fonctions je suis
convaincu que vous avez perçu ces
difficultés que nous avons nous sommes
confrontés comme l'état comme les
communes à des difficultés quotidiennes
de fermetures d'entreprise de
difficultés auxquelles nous essayons
aujourd'hui comme avec le monde
associatif de ne pas d investir nous
considérons dans les collectivités
je sais bien que les budgets des
communes ces 128 milliards aux 110
milliards le budget du département c'est
70 milliards que le budget des régions
ça n'est que 35 milliards ou un peu
moins mais dans ce domaine
nous devons
je crois pouvoir avancer avec beaucoup
de raison avec modération mais aussi
avec innovation pour plus d'horizon pour
nos territoires
je ne ferai pas ce qu'avait fait
l'ancien chef de l'état serre collègues
qui j'avais eu un jour ce débat avec lui
dans une usine qui travaille pour le
nucléaire dans la métal valley nord
côte-d'or et la veggie moi je veux des
usines je ne veux pas de collectivités
locales il ne faut pas opposer les
entreprises aux collectivités locales
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya une
difficulté dans les entreprises ce sont
les collectivités locales qui assume la
responsabilité et qui sont là pour
réparer les dégâts
demain après demain je recevrai encore
des salariés d'entreprises qui dans les
sites ferment brutalement on leur dit
s'affirmera le 1er juillet les
collectivités locales sont là pour
réparer
souvent les difficultés donc ne les
oppose ont pas et moi je fais confiance
au gouvernement pour faire à la fois une
réforme des collectivités et une réforme
des finances locales qui sera tenir
compte de ce qui a été bien fait dans
toute réforme fiscale mais il sait aussi
tenir compte des échecs et des
évaluations qui n'ont pas été faites
pour pouvoir fournir à ces collectivités
les moyens d'assumer leurs missions dans
la foi dans le dynamisme dans la
sérénité et dans l'égalité merci merci
dernier intervenant la parole est à
monsieur claude bérit-debat pour le
groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je voudrais à mon tour
étant le dernier orateur et pour ne pas
me distinguer rendre hommage à votre
prédécesseur monsieur le ministre jérôme
cahuzac et vous dire tout le plaisir que
j'ai personnellement de vous voir
occuper cette fonction
connaissant à la fois vos compétences et
votre pugnacité dans jean ministère qui
est particulièrement important
la question de la suppression de la tp
fait incontestablement partie de ses
sujets dont le sénat représentant des
collectivités locales ne peut manquer de
s'intéresser et ce à plusieurs titres et
les orateurs précédents montrent que en
fonction de la leur je dirais fonctions
électives
ils indiquent qu'ils appuient plutôt sur
l'un sur telle situation l'autre sur tel
autre situation
ils le doivent sénat
c'est cette importance d'autant plus que
cette réforme n'a pas eu quoi qu'on en
dise des effets économiques escomptées
ce premier point mérite que nous
arrêtions en tant que parlementaire nous
devons dont nous interroger sur la
pertinence de cette réforme
on sait plus ou moins ce qu'elle coûte à
l'état ça vient d'être dit par mon
collègue patriat et aux collectivités
mais on ignore ce qu'elle leur apporte
notamment en termes économiques et en
second lieu et c'est l'objet du rapport
à l'origine de ce départ
les conséquences du remplacement de la
taxe professionnelle par la cnt de reto
précisément établie la fiscalité locale
a été c'est peu de le dire profondément
bouleversé par cette réforme
ces bouleversements sont de deux ordres
la réforme a d'abord affecté la
composition du panier fiscal des
collectivités
cette dimension fiscale a eu ensuite
d'importantes répercussions sur l'action
de ces collectivités et notamment sur
des stratégies de mouvements qu'elle met
en place
certains d'entre nous il était de ceux
là avaient exprimé lors de l'adoption de
la réforme la crainte que la suppression
de la tp engendre une perte de dynamisme
des ressources fiscales
cette craintes étaient fondées j'en veux
pour preuve que le bloc communal dont il
est admis qu'il savait finalement le
moins mal tiré a été profondément
affectée par la suppression de la tp
cela se vérifie notamment au niveau des
et pci qui avait comme seule ressource
fiscale l'atp eu la communauté
d'agglomération que je préside avait
fait au départ le choix de la tp sans
taxes ménages additionnel cette relative
simplicité fiscal avait deux avantages
elle avait d'abord favoriser le
renforcement du lien intercommunale elle
avait ensuite permis d'élaborer un plan
de développement fondé sur un dynamisme
prévisible de recettes fiscales sans
plus
les ménages cette époque qui m'apparaît
rétrospectivement particulièrement
intéressante et bien révolue notre
recette unique a été remplacé par sept
autres lignes de recettes d'origine
économique je ne reviendrai pas sur le
bétail ou en provenance des ménages des
recettes transférées d'autres
collectivités pour certaines sans parier
de la variable d'ajustement qui est le
fnj
la conséquence de tout cela et le
rapport l'établi très bien monsieur le
rapporteur c'est que l'autonomie fiscale
des communautés s'est dégradée la
réforme
and if any notamment conduit à une forte
augmentation de la part des impôts
ménage dans les ressources fiscales du
bloc communal
ainsi dans ma communauté nous sommes
passés d'un financement à 100% par la
tpe à un financement provenant à hauteur
de 45 % des taxes ménages dans ces
conditions l'autonomie financière et
fiscale dont je suis censé disposer en
théorie et en pratique mans et en
pratique concrètement très réduite
se pose alors le deuxième problème qui
lui n'est plus fiscale mais financier et
économique
comment définir dans ces conditions une
stratégie d'investissement aussi
efficace que celle que nous avions pu
bénéficier à partir de là celle des pays
très concrètement et je le vois encore
aujourd'hui puisque nous avons mené
notre débat d'orientation budgétaire que
nous allons voter le budget dans notre
communauté
vendredi prochain je dois encore très
concrètement la recette de notre tp eut
augmenté en moyenne sur notre territoire
de 4,5 ou rang 4 5% par an or la
suppression de la tp s'est traduite par
deux ans du gel entre 2009 et 2011 par
le fait du fnj et la dynamique de nos
ressources a été rompu entre 2009 et
notre produit fiscal a augmenté de 0 4%
à 0 4% alors que nous avions une bonne
dynamique de 4 5% par an mais dans le
même temps et je crois que tout le monde
en est conscient
les attentes en matière
d'investissements n'ont pas baissé
encore plus en période de crise les
collectivités constitue une source
d'investissements indispensables au
soutien de l'activité économique et aux
besoins sociaux de nos concitoyens un
certain nombre de d'orateur présidents
ont rappelé le rôle que jouent les
collectivités territoriales dans les
investissements et les chiffres
d'affaires qui sont ainsi alloués aux
entreprises du bâtiment où des travaux
publics puisque 70% des investissements
autour de 110 % sont assurés par les
collectivités territoriales
c'est donc toute une stratégie de
développement économique et social qui
doit être repensée pouvant conduire à un
réajustement forcément à la baisse de
nos priorités d'action au total juge
dont je dirais que la suppression de la
tp est intervenue au plus mauvais moment
en terme de conjoncture économique
elle a aussi rendu l'action prisonnière
d'un carcan fiscale qui de toute
évidence ne répond pas aux besoins des
collectivités
à ce titre est une encore et c'est
encore un autre aspect les mécanismes de
péréquation qui ont été mis en place
sont encore très insatisfaisant
puisqu'il ne permettent pas de corriger
suffisamment les disparités
territoriales
c'est d'autant plus inacceptable pour
ces rencontres que en fin de compte la
suppression de la tp
ap a généré dans les territoires le coup
de fouet escomptés en termes
développement économique
certaines professions ont bénéficié
indiscutablement d'effets d'aubaine
important globalement la plupart des
secteurs d'activité ont tiré profit de
la suppression de la tp mais s'il
fallait mettre en évidence ou mettre en
balance ses bénéfices avec le coût que
cela représente pour la collectivité
je ne suis pas du tout sûr que l'on
parvienne un équilibre satisfaisant
aussi la réforme des collectivités
territoriales doit être l'occasion de
rétablir une fiscalité équitable des
collectivités territoriales de redoux
permettent de rétablir une fiscalité
équitable et dynamique qui redonne tout
son sens à l'idée d'autonomie financière
et fiscale et je ferai mienne la
plaidoirie de notre collègue patriat en
la ramenant au niveau des épées ci et ça
on en restait simplement au niveau des
régions parce que le problème est le
même c'est un problème d'économie
d'échelle mais le problème est le même
c'est pour ça que dans ces conditions
c'est dans ces conditions là que l'on
pourra redonner aux collectivités les
marges de manoeuvre dont elles ont
effectivement besoin
c'est ce que je souhaite de façon très
forte monsieur le ministre
et j'espère que nous serons entendus
dans les prochains textes qui seront
présentés à notre haute assemblée merci
monsieur le ministre vous accueillir mon
tour et en vous souhaitant plein de
réussite dans vos nouvelles fonctions je
vous passe la parole le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
très sincèrement pour avoir pris
l'initiative de ce débat dont les
différentes interventions ont témoigné
de l'importance puisqu'il renvoie à un
sujet très central pour l'ensemble de
ceux qui administrent des collectivités
locales je veux parler de leurs
relations financières entre l'état les
collectivités territoriales qui garantit
l'autonomie financière et fiscale de ces
dernières est garanti qu'elles seront
situation dans la crise d'assurer les
investissements dans le pays a besoin
pour créer les conditions de la
croissance ce débat est un débat
extrêmement important pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce qu'il intervient à
la veille de la redéfinition par l'état
de ses relations financières et fiscales
avec les collectivités territoriales
conformément à ce qu'a annoncé le
premier ministre à l'occasion de sa
déclaration du 12 12 mars
ce débat interne est également à la
veille de la troisième étape de la
décentralisation annoncé par le
président de la république et le premier
ministre
il intervient aussi vous l'avez souligné
monsieur le sénateur gani un moment où
l'état doit rendre compte devant votre
assemblée comme devant l'assemblée
nationale
des conditions dans lesquelles s'est
accompli la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle conformément d'ailleurs
aux textes législatifs établissant cette
réforme de 2010 et même si le précédent
gouvernement n'a pas présenté les
documents relatifs au bilan de la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle à la
fin de l'année 2011
l'actuel gouvernement a souhaité que
cette photographie vous soit donnée et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
présenté un rapport qui a fait l'objet
d'un débat devant le comité des finances
locales
au mois de novembre dernier qui établit
un certain nombre de conclusions et met
en évidence un certain nombre d'éléments
qui recoupe en grande partie les
conclusions du rapport que vous avez
élaboré et dont je veux saluer monsieur
le sénateur laquelle il
des conclusions en même temps que la
hauteur de vue qui a présidé à son
élaboration et dans votre intervention
aujourd'hui témoigne une fois de plus
s'il en était besoin
je voudrais monsieur le sénateur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme l'a fait le sénateur gainey il ya
de cela quelques instants relayé par
l'ensemble des orateurs de tous les
groupes qui se sont succédé à cette
tribune évoqué trois sujets qui
permettront je l'espère d'apporter une
partie significative des réponses aux
questions que vous avez soulevé les uns
et des autres le premier sujet concerne
l'impact pour le monde de l'entreprise
de la réforme de la taxe professionnelle
puisque l'objectif poursuivi par le
précédent gouvernement aidé de procéder
à une réforme qui allège la pression
fiscale pesant sur les entreprises de
manière à améliorer leur compétitivité
il est intéressant donc de regarder les
conditions dans lesquelles objectif a
été atteint par rapport aux ambitions
que le texte de 2010 avait porté la
deuxième question qui doit être traité
et celle des conséquences pour l'état il
ya une compensation pour l'état de la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle
cette compensation n'est pas maudit
qu'en termes de moyens mobilisés il nous
faut regarder les conditions dans
lesquelles cette compensation est
mobilisé et surtout les conditions dans
lesquelles nous pouvons dans la durée la
maîtriser et personne ne comprendrait
que le ministre du budget fut-il nouveau
ne se préoccupe a pas de cette question
et puis enfin il ya une troisième
interrogation que vous avez évoqué les
uns les autres c'est la question de
l'impact de la réforme pour les
collectivités territoriales elle même
commençons donc par traiter de la
question de l'effet pour les entreprises
de cette réforme de la taxe
professionnelle qui était destiné à
améliorer de façon significative leur
compétitivité d'abord je veux souligner
comme l'ont fait un très grand nombre
d'orateurs soin de vue là le rapport du
sénateur guinée est extrêmement précis
l'effet de recomposition sectorielle
engendrées par la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle et quand on regarde quel
est l'impact sur les différents secteurs
d'activités du nouveau dispositif mis en
oeuvre on ne peut pas ne pas constater
qu'ils affectent les différents secteurs
d'activités de façon contrastée selon
leur nature ou selon les activités
qu'ils développent je vais prendre
quelques exemples très concrets
nous avons un impact très positif de la
réforme sur le secteur de bâtiment qui
voit ses contributions et sa pression
fiscale diminué d'à peu près 40 6%
nous voyons un effet positif sur le
secteur de l'industrie qui bénéficie
d'un effet de diminution de ses
contributions à hauteur de 29%
nous voyons un effet de stabilisation de
la contribution apportée par le secteur
financier
et lorsque l'on fait un focus sur un
certain nombre de secteurs de services
de secteurs industriels
on se rend compte que les entreprises y
ont le plus bénéficié de la réforme sont
celles des secteurs de l'automobile ce
qui n'est pas neutre compte tenu de la
crise à laquelle ce secteur se trouve
confronté puisqu'il y a un effet de
diminution de la contribution de ce
secteur de près de 74% et que les
entreprises qui ont le moins bénéficié
de cette réforme sur les entreprises
financières puisqu'un certain nombre
accuse une augmentation de leur
contribution de l'ordre de 35%
il y a donc un effet très différents
selon les secteurs d'activité concernés
de cette réforme
le deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
insister concernant l'impact pour les
entreprises de la réforme à laquelle il
a été procédé c'est sur l'augmentation
assez dynamique de la cvae
je pense qu'il faut avoir
vous l'avez souhaité les uns les autres
beaucoup d'honnêteté et de rigueur dans
ce débat on est sûr que les chiffres ne
mentent jamais lorsqu'il s'agit
d'apprécier des évolutions et par
conséquent si l'on veut comme vous
l'avez souhaité sur tous les bancs de
cet hémicycle avoir une contribution à
la réflexion sur les relations entre
l'état les collectivités locales en
matière de finances publiques
honnête et rigoureuse il faut s'en tenir
à ce que disent les chiffres et les
chiffres disent que la cvae a été
dynamique pour les collectivités
territoriales
la question n'est pas de savoir si la
cvae été dynamiques ou pas la question
même de sa vie
à terme si la dynamique de la cvm ne
risque pas d'aboutir à un grignotage de
l'effet de la réforme laquelle il a été
procédé sur la compétitivité des
entreprises je veux donner un chiffre
simple entre 2010 et 2011 le produit de
la tva a augmenté de 9% et représenter
en termes de produit une évolution de
près de 1 milliard donc nous devons
regarder de très près la manière dont
évolue cette contribution qui est plutôt
dynamique sur les entreprises
le troisième point sur lequel je
voudrais insister c'est sur l'impact de
cette réforme sur les petites et
moyennes entreprises
si nous voulons que cette réforme soit
positif pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises
il faut particulièrement être attentif à
la manière dont la fiscalité s'applique
à elle et vous avez remarqué que nous
avons maintenu le dispositif de
dégrèvement barémique dont bénéficie un
certain nombre de petites et moyennes
entreprises je rappelle que le
dégrèvement est totale pour les petites
et moyennes entreprises dont le chiffre
d'affaires est inférieur à 500 mille
euros et qu'il y ait un processus de
dégressivité du dégrèvement pour les
entreprises dont le chiffre d'affaires
est entre cinq cent mille euros et 50
millions d'euros
ce dispositif garantit que les mesures
fiscales qui ont été mises en oeuvre en
faveur des pme pmi tiennent compte de la
nécessité d'encourager ce secteur pour
faire en sorte qu'il garde sa dynamique
au moment où nous savons dans le pays
une grande partie de la croissance de la
capacité d'innovation est tenu par ce
secteur et petites et moyennes
entreprises devrait également assister
sur un point qui a été évoqué dans votre
rapport monsieur le sénateur qui la
nécessité de ne pas faire d
de l'imposition forfaitaire sur les
entreprises de réseaux un dispositif qui
viserait à mettre en oeuvre une
contribution généralisée sur toute
l'économie que représente des
entreprises de réseaux il est très
important de veiller à ce que la
mobilisation de l'ifer n'interviennent
que dès lors qu'il ya un décalage très
important entre le volume de produit
fiscal applicable à ces entreprises à
l'époque où elles se voyaient appliquer
la taxe professionnelle et le dispositif
fiscal qui s'applique elle après que la
réforme est intervenue et généralement
les collectivités locales ont été
raisonnables et on fait en sorte que
l'on mobilise l'ifer simplement
lorsqu'il y avait eu non seulement une
neutralité mais un effet d'aubaine de la
réforme pour les entreprises de réseaux
vous suivre dans votre rapport qu'il est
nécessaire de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas un dispositif général qui
s'applique que l'on veille à ce que lee
faire de se mobiliser que lorsqu'il ya
ce processus de décrochage résulte en un
passage d'imposition à un autre je veux
là aussi dire notre préoccupation est
notre accord avec cette proposition du
rapport
je veux dire quelques mots également sur
des sujets qui ont été évoqués par tous
les orateurs et qui concerne les
conséquences pour un certain nombre de
petites entreprises de l'augmentation de
la cotisation minimale à la cfe à
laquelle il a été procédé de la part de
certaines communes de façon imprudente
ce qui a conduit à des augmentations
absolument dramatique de contribution
pour des entreprises qui est déjà était
déjà très fragilisés par la crise et qui
a conduit le gouvernement loi de
finances rectificative à prendre des
dispositions destinées à corriger les
effets de ce type de difficultés nous
l'avons fait en loi de finances
rectificative en prenant des
dispositions qui permettent aux communes
qui le souhaitent jusqu'au 21 janvier
donc cela a été fait de corriger les
effets de l'augmentation de cette
cotisation minimale cfe et nous avons
également mis en place un dispositif qui
permet
aux communes qui le souhaitent
d'exonérer de 50% la contribution de cf
pour les entreprises dont le chiffre
d'affaires est inférieur à dix mille
euros
ce dispositif est en oeuvre il a permis
des corrections mais bien entendu il ne
doit pas altérer notre vigilance pour
l'avenir vous avez également assisté
beaucoup dans les documents que vous
avez élaboré dans les interventions que
vous avez faite sur le statut de l'auto
entrepreneur et l'exonération de cf dont
il bénéficie il faut savoir que sur
cette question
nous avons pris des dispositions loi de
finances rectificatif pour proroger le
dispositif d'exonération de cfe dont
bénéficient aujourd'hui les auto
entrepreneurs
il est important pour nous avant de
procéder à des mesures définitives en la
matière de regarder quelles sont les
conclusions des inspections et autres
évaluations en cours de telle manière à
bien mesurer l'impact de cette mesure et
la nécessité ou pas de la généraliser
voilà ce que je voulais dire concernant
les dispositifs applicables aux
entreprises et qui permettent de mesurer
quelles sont les conséquences de la
réforme sur le tissu économique en
sachant bien entendu que le gouvernement
s'emploiera dans les mois qui viennent à
la faveur des débats budgétaires et des
séances que nous aurons sur la loi de
finances et autres dispositifs pour
faire toute la transparence sur l'impact
sur les entreprises de la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle
deuxième sujet sur lequel je voudrais
dire un mot c'est les conséquences pour
l'état de la réforme à laquelle il a été
procédé vous avez madame la sénatrice
insisté
comme d'autres orateurs jean marie
bockel a fait également sur le volume
deux contributions budgétaires de l'état
à la réforme qui est de 4 milliards et
je ne peux pas ne pas m'interroger sur
bien entendu la nécessité pour l'état
d'assumer ses obligations vis-à-vis des
collectivités locales parce que c'est un
langage un engagement fort du
gouvernement du premier ministre sur la
nécessité aussi de maîtriser cette
contribution dans le temps puisque vous
avez eu pour un certain nombre d'entre
vous la sagesse de reconnaître qu'il y
avait une obligation conjointe des
parlementaires du gouvernement de
veiller au rétablissement de nos comptes
et que c'est un exercice dans lequel
nous pouvons nous engager de concert et
je ne peux pas ne pas avoir à l'esprit
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
concernant l'assiette applicables aux
bénéfices non commerciaux pour les
entreprises de moins de cinq salariés
qui a eu un impact qui pouvait avoir un
impact sur le volume de la dotation
allouée par l'état à cette réforme
et comme vous le savez des dispositions
ont été prises dès lors que le conseil
constitutionnel avait fait connaître le
droit et que le droit étant passée il
avait un impact budgétaire pour l'état
nous avons essayé de compenser l'effet
de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel en mettant en place une
nouvelle tranche entre cent mille deux
cent cinquante mille euros pour la
contribution foncière
des entreprises de manière à compenser
l'effet de cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel
je veux dire également concerne en
l'état que j'ai bien entendu et je la
trouve légitime cette demande
la volonté qui s'est exprimé sur tous
les bancs de voir l'état rendre compte
de façon précise en toute transparence
des conditions dans lesquelles ils
organisent la relation avec les
collectivités territoriales en matière
financière en général et plus
particulièrement pour ce qui concerne le
sujet qui est à l'ordre du jour de nos
débats je veux dire que le fameux jaune
qui rend compte des relations
financières entre les collectivités
locales et l'état sera suffisamment
documenté pour que vous puissiez être
assuré que la volonté de transparence
que j'évoque à l'instant ne sera pas
simplement verbal mais qu'elle sera
garanti par l'état dans de bonnes
conditions
enfin je veux dire un mot pour conclure
sur les collectivités territoriales
parce que nous devons nous poser la
question de la conséquence de cette
réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales les multiples
interventions certains d'ailleurs je
pense à l'intervention du président
patriat faisant un focus sur la
situation particulière de certaines
collectivités territoriales je pense
notamment aux régions ont montré que la
situation des collectivités locales
devant la réforme est très contrastée
selon la nature des collectivités
locales dont il est question
d'abord nous savons que les communes et
les intercommunalités bénéficie d'un
panier de ressources très diversifié qui
garantit malgré la réforme qu'elles
pourront agir sur le taux pour assurer
la dynamique de leurs ressources pour ce
qui concerne les départements le dans le
panier de ressources dont disposent les
départements la relation entre la
ressource ménager la ressource
entreprise n'a pas été modifiée au point
que les ressources des départements s'en
trouve modifiée même si les départements
sont confrontés à un réel problème qui
est celui de l'effet de ciseau dont ils
sont victimes et qui les conduit à voir
des charges qui augmentent et des
ressources moins dynamique
l'augmentation des charges auxquelles
ils doivent faire face
et par ailleurs il ya la situation
particulière des régions dont le
président patriat a indiqué monsieur le
sénateur patrie indiqué à l'instant
qu'elle avait pu pâtir de la réforme
puisque leur niveau d'autonomie fiscale
s'en est trouvée amoindri et qu'elle
dépense ne dépende plus aux termes de la
réforme de la dotation de l'état
qu'avant que la réforme ne se mette en
oeuvre du fait de la disparition d'une
grande partie des contributions
foncières dont ont bénéficié les régions
du fait de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
donc on ne peut pas ne pas tenir compte
lorsque l'on raisonne sur les
conséquences de la réforme sur les
collectivités locales du caractère très
contrastée de la situation des
collectivités locales en raison de la
spécificité de chacune d'elles le
deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
insister concernant les collectivités
territoriales c'est que nous sommes bien
entendu soucieux de faire en sorte que
des mécanismes de correction ou de
garanties de leurs ressources soient
mises en oeuvre
pour ce qui concerne les départements
il y à un fonds d'urgence de 170
millions d'euros qui a été mis en oeuvre
ce fonds d'urgence il est destiné à
permettre au département de faire face à
leurs charges obligatoires mais nous
vous devront bien entendu regarder de
très près les conditions dans lesquelles
ce fonds immobilisés et les conditions
dans lesquelles il est en situation de
répondre à la situation des départements
dont on sait que les charges sociales
particulières auxquelles ils doivent
faire face augmente de façon
significative pour ce qui concerne les
communes le gouvernement a pris
l'engagement d'engager le processus de
révision des valeurs locatives
nous verrons les conditions dans
lesquelles cela se déroule est de nature
à créer les conditions de la garantie
des ressources communales et
intercommunales et puis nous avons la
situation des régions particulières avec
des expertises et des investigations en
cours qui nous permettront d'examiner de
près la demande qui a pu être formulées
par certains acteurs de voir mises en
place en faveur des
région un versement transport tout cela
mérite expertise
attention tout cela mérite analyse et le
gouvernement saura au terme des analyses
auxquelles il est procédé qu'il
expertisera sera prendre les décisions
qui relèvent de sa responsabilité
je voudrais également dire quelques mots
sur le dispositif de péréquation qui a
été évoquée par un certain nombre
d'orateurs je voudrais le faire en
évoquant la situation de chacune des
catégories de collectivités locales
avant de conclure tout d'abord le pic
qui concerne plus particulièrement les
communes et les intercommunalités voit
désormais prises en compte pour son
alimentation
le revenu par habitant cela est destiné
à faire en sorte que ce fonds puisse
être alimenté par des collectivités
locales qui sont plus que d'autres en
situation de le faire et que
l'alimentation de ce fonds donne coup
toutes garanties d'équité dans la
manière dont il est alimenté est
mobilisé et cela constitue un progrès
qui peut en appeler d'autres
mais qu'il faut noter au moment où nous
en sommes de la réforme
le deuxième point concerne la
péréquation pour les départements
il ya deux fonds de péréquation pour les
départements et aussi ont fait l'objet
d'évolutions qu'il faut noter et qui
sont pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles positives pour ce qui concerne les
départements le premier fonds mobilisés
de péréquation et celui des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux pour ce qui
concerne l'alimentation de ce fonds le
critère du revenu par habitant également
été pris en compte pour assurer que sont
bien les départements les plus riches
dont la capacité de mobilisation est la
plus forte qui participeront le plus à
l'alimentation de ce four mais pour ce
qui concerne la distribution de ce fonds
d'autres critères sont intervenus et les
départements qui bénéficieront de la
mobilisation de la péréquation au titre
de ce fonds des droits de mutation à
titre onéreux sont ceux dont le
potentiel de revenu par habitant où le
revenu par habitant est inférieur à la
moyenne nationale des revenus des
départements ce qui garantira là aussi
que des progrès dans la manière dont la
péréquation s'organise avec l'objectif
d'équité de justice seront bien accompli
pour ce qui concerne la péréquation cvae
dont peuvent bénéficier les départements
elle a permis de la mobilisation de 60
millions d'euros à partir de critères
dont 80% renvoie à ce que sont les
compétences régaliennes et départements
qu'il s'agisse du nombre de personnes
âgées de plus de 75 ans du nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa ou du revenu par
habitant qui mesure ce qu'est la
situation socio économique de ces
collectivités locales
enfin répondent en cela à une
préoccupation exprimée par le président
patriat nous devons nous interroger sur
la péréquation dont bénéficient les
régions parce que comme vous l'avez
indiqué elles sont celles dont
l'autonomie financière c'est la plus
réduite au cours des différentes étapes
de la réforme et qui doit bénéficier par
conséquent du dispositif de péréquation
le plus élaboré le plus achevé
de ce point de vue là aussi des progrès
ont été accomplis puisque l'assiette des
ressources fiscales à partir de laquelle
est calculé la péréquation intègre
désormais l'ensemble des ressources et
impôts résultant de la mise en oeuvre du
nouveau dispositif et permet également
de mobiliser le prélèvement sur le flux
cumulés de cette ressource
ce n'est sans doute pas encore tout à
fait suffisant mais c'est un progrès
dont il faut tenir compte
dès lors que l'on cherche à faire ce que
vous êtes employé à faire tout au long
de cette séance c'est à dire à évaluer
cette réforme et à définir les
conditions dans lesquelles elle peut
être optimisé avec la volonté de faire
en sorte que cette réforme qui a été
décidée puisse aboutir à une relation
transparente entre l'état les
collectivités locales et ne prive pas
les collectivités locales de leurs
ressources
voyez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je me suis employé à travers
cet exposé que j'ai voulu nécessairement
très objectif est assez peu passionnel
parce que ces sujets ne mérite pas
d'être abordée de façon passionnée mais
objective vous dire l'état d'esprit qui
est celui du gouvernement et par delà la
question de la taxe professionnelle vous
dire quel est l'esprit du gouvernement
pour ce qui concerne la relation
financière entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
nous sommes à la veille d'un nouvel acte
de décentralisation c'est nouvel acte de
décentralisation est destinée à donner
aux collectivités locales les moyens qui
leur permettront de se mobiliser autour
de l'objectif de redressement qui
préside à la mise en oeuvre de la
politique de ce gouvernement cela
suppose que les collectivités locales
puissent être raisonnablement appelé à
l'effort de redressement tant la
difficulté et grandes qui mérite que
nous nous rassemblions pour la surmonter
mais en même temps dès lors que nous
sommes ensemble pour surmonter la
difficulté nous devons être capables
d'être ensemble dans l'exigence de
transparence
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
profitais de 7 da pour dire à la
représentation nationale notamment à
vous-même qui représentait beaucoup les
collectivités territoriales de notre
pays
la volonté sur les sujets que vous
abordez aujourd'hui de vous garantir la
transparence de vous garantir
l'information d'approfondir avec vous la
réflexion et le débat ce que votre
assemblée d'ailleurs mérite
compte tenu de la haute qualité du débat
qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui et de la très
grande qualité du rapport qui a présidé
à son organisation je vous remercie
voilà pour ce débat consacré aux
conséquences de la suppression de la
taxe professionnelle si vous souhaitez
le revoir il est disponible en vod sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr